alright hey what's going on guys it's
jake thank you for all the support on
the elden ring videos i've been having a
ton of fun making these videos so i'm
just gonna keep making if you keep
watching them so make sure to subscribe
today i'm gonna show you where you can
get this armor it's called haslow's
armor and it's freaking sick it's part
of the volcano manor quest line that
you'll see in the video let's get it
i'm talking about this chick i am
pleased
to have you on a side she likes me
argues now what do i do see who's in
here we still got uh this chick who has
the worst posture i've ever seen why
does he look so distressed this guy's
struggling thing is i have my own
problems to deal with buddy so we go
here i just haven't done it yet
there's a glitch i found it's called all
that f4 bro it's called all f4 bro
invade rayleigh the idol's world
oh no
yeah that was really easy see you've
performed another task for us it will
oh
blade
the lord's visits with our champions are
always a spectacle
you cannot come a day too soon
well what do i do for that ah new
contract
a red letter you know
oh okay wait is that her is that why
your posture was so bad oh my god i'm
afraid this is not a guest room goodness
am i still a serpent
so did i just barge into her room sorry
you left the door open
okay so what did the letter say a
written request from all kinder man was
disclosing the name of a tarnish to be
hunted juno hoslow knight of blood you
can be found in the mountaintops of the
giants find the red mark on your map for
the exact location i've been there what
is that
what are you showing me
hollows oath
oslo's oath
oh whip
okay lots of damage
i'm an idiot
oh i'm dead
i'm dead
a little greedy there he has no more
health this guy hits for a lot i really
need to get more vigor
oh the bleed
the bleed yo i got his armor and his
whip
oh my god his armor looks sick huh okay
like who is this
look at this i like it
yeah
yeah yeah